ray Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area senior
insider and I wanted to talk to Ray
about what's going on with my Oakland
Raiders good morning ray tell me what's
going on here with behind the scenes
with the Raiders and the possibility of
is Derek Carr on this team
next Tuesday next Tuesday yes he will
not right if you want to say next July
no I don't think so the the salary cap
implications of moving him now are too
considerable but if they wait till after
to him first
they save a boatload of money on the cap
plus you know if if you really wanted to
stick your finger in the eye of a fan
base that you're already abandoning that
would be the way because as erratic as
car has been he basically is now the
only thing left for this fan base to
claim to Marshawn Lynch is probably not
going to play again this year Amari
Cooper is gone even though you know he
was sort of problematic and Khalil Mac's
gone so really you know you trade your
quarterback and basically you are saying
we are closed for business
don't come around night anymore and
that's you know that's that's the place
where for Marc Marc Davis probably tells
John calm down I'm getting hammered here
so no he'll be if they trade him there's
a level of insanity that I think John
Gurdon is capable of but he'll pay for
it for years to come all right but if
the Raiders weren't moving to Vegas
would they be making all of these moves
probably because look Jon Gruden lives
in a football only vacuum and one of the
reasons why I think he was surprised
that it has played that this rebuild has
played so poorly is because he's not on
the same timeline everybody else is he's
the coach of the Raiders he's not
necessarily the coach of the Oakland
Raiders and I think that was the
disconnect in fact he referenced it
yesterday in his sort of casual midweek
presser you know he said I want to do
the best we want to do the best we can
for the Oakland Raiders and for the
Raiders you know it's like there's two
separate entities to him and you know
that's an insane way to live but it's
the deal he took for the hundred million
dollars and he sort of compartmentalize
this into Oakland can't be my problem so
yeah I think he would have blown this up
the way he blew it up but I think the
backlash would not have been nearly as
great there would have been backlash
because the Raiders did a complete
rebuild six years ago after Al Davis
died and now they're doing another one
and this is not a franchise that's been
particularly proud over the last quarter
century so the the fans would have been
hot but not like this because he not
only said I want to bring the
championship to Oakland in his first
presser know which we knew was you know
not very likely but to say well when I
said championship what I meant was a two
and fourteen year I mean that's that's
how you sort of lose people who are
already hard about losing a team but I
also look at this rate and and sometimes
when you you send a known commodity and
you trade them like Hello Mac and even a
Mari Cooper but if if we take a step
back and and we're not knee-deep in
fandom and go okay did they make the
right moves here given what the bigger
picture is did they get enough for Chlo
Mac and they got a first-round pick from
the Cowboys from Amari Cooper those are
those positives are being spun that way
in Oakland nobody no-nobody the cooper
deal is a good deal because they got
more than they had any right to expect
given the fact that they were they had
no more useful they didn't know how to
get him to be the receiver they drafted
and I think they had just finally said
look let's just move him and the fact
that Jerry Jones is equally desperate
and equally nuts and offered a first
there's nothing wrong with that deal in
a vacuum the Mac deal I think in him
you could you could defend the notion
well they got to first
but chakras drafting history is not good
and in either event you're not going to
get a player in the draft as good as
Khalil Mack so I think that's harder
that that's a harder one to sell but
it's more just the idea that Garuda was
brought here to make the fanbase feel
good in the two years it had left and
instead he sort of said well you know
what I need to do is not what you want
to see and so they're not buying it
and they're not you know so I didn't
answer your question yeah it it would
have been more benign were they staying
but because they're not it's really you
know everybody hates everybody now it's
a much life but has he lost the locker
room I think there are a lot of people
in a locker room who know that they are
very much short timers and I think that
you know that as much as anything is
true because when you move math and then
you move Cooper after saying you're not
gonna move Cooper yeah all of a sudden
everybody's in play and when everybody's
in play everybody's nervous and the
coach can't tell you anything you're
going to believe because he's already on
the hook for having lied to you before I
mean when he told the team that he
wasn't going to trade Amari Cooper and
then quote something came up well you
don't think an absolute you just you
just don't you you say you know look you
know we're we're not look rich we're not
a good place right now
anything could happen but I'm not clear
but I'm not looking to trade anybody you
know but you you sort of couch it so
that there's a possibility that
something could happen from what we've
been able to glean so far all they heard
was we're not trading Amari Cooper and
then you know days later Cooper is
traded and then they don't get told
right away they learned from swine like
us and that really frosted them so yeah
I think I think in large part you know
for a bunch of different reasons he has
lost the room and I don't know that he
can get it back because he can't make a
convincing argument that
these are the guys he wants to build
with because it's they're clearly not
the guys he wants to build with he wants
to redo this team from the ground up so
they know they're you know they know
they're playing for another job
somewhere I don't believe they're gonna
quit but I don't believe they're gonna
give the hundred and first percent that
Gordon always insists they do very good
to talk to you and we appreciate the
time as always well you know following
great Kinnear is so easy for anybody
thank you bright it's a ray Ratto NBC
Sports Bay Area for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]